good afternoon my name is Claude Steele
I'm the Provost of Columbia University
and it is my great pleasure to welcome
you this afternoon to a world leaders
forum events sponsored in conjunction
with Columbia's Earth Institute the
focus of today's program is the drylands
initiative a project announced at the
start of 2000 intend to address the
challenges faced by people living in
arid and semi-arid lands six nations of
East and Southern Africa are
participating in the initiative many of
them are assembled here represented here
to today and I want to welcome each of
our distinguished guests to Colombia
this afternoon thank you for making the
time to be with us Columbia University
President Lee Bollinger launched the
world leaders forum in 2003 as a
university-wide initiative to support
uninhibited dialogue on the most
pressing economic political
environmental and social questions of
our time questions that with each
passing year have grown larger and
larger in global dimensions over the
past seven years the forum has offered
an opportunity for more than 15,000
students faculty and staff to directly
engage important figures from 48 nations
representing really every corner of the
globe our experience has confirmed the
animating principle of the forum that
only through informed dialogue critical
scholarship and a free exchange of ideas
will answers emerge to the biggest
problems facing the world today the role
of universities in creating a space for
uninhibited and critical discussion of
controversial issues has been noted on
many occasions if anything the changes
we are seeing in public discourse serve
to heighten the importance of this role
universities not only are places where
difficult conversations are respected
and encouraged today it seems that
universities may be the only remaining
venues where such conversations can
occur with any regularity
in the world leaders forum being held at
Columbia this week our university
community once again will hear from a
broad and dynamic group of political
leaders the diversity of viewpoints
presented as part of the forum is a
principal measure of its success while
providing a university form does not
imply an endorsement of the views
expressed in these addresses or the
policies pursued by these governments we
have a responsibility as a global center
of learning to offer our community the
chance to engage in conversations with
men and women directly involved in
meeting major challenges of the 21st
century no one ever said these
conversations would be easy in the case
of the drylands initiative the
challenges are large and complex
touching on climate change poverty
religion infrastructure public health
farming and an animal production
commerce and trade transportation
communications legal systems in a 21st
century many problems demand an
interdisciplinary response but none more
so than the challenges of the drylands
one change essential to the success of
this initiative is to set aside once and
for all the common view among
policymakers in Africa that dry lands
are a liability rather than an asset
wastelands instead of areas to be
cultivated for that task one could
scarcely find a better suited
organization than our own earth
institute or a more effective advocate
than its director Jeffrey Sachs
professor Sachs is currently special
advisor to the United Nations
secretary-general ban ki-moon from 2002
to 2006 he directed the United Nations
Millennium Project and advised the UN
secretary-general kofi annan on the
Millennium Development Goals please join
me in welcoming the director of
Columbia's Earth Institute Jeffrey Sachs
ladies and gentlemen thank you very much
for being here in the quad thank you
very much for hosting us and for that
wonderful introduction we're running a
little bit late because it's a very
complicated week as I'm sure you're
aware there are about a hundred forty
world leaders in town right now that
spells big traffic jams and lots of
interesting side meetings and very
difficult schedules people are here on
the 10th anniversary of the millennium
development goals as surely we know at
Columbia that's a 15-year effort and we
are in the 10th year of that 15-year
effort and it's a challenge it's a
struggle because achieving the
Millennium Development Goals is a matter
of very complex partnerships and
cooperation and we live in a world and
at a time when cooperation is hard and
the kind of cooperation that's needed is
cooperation that is international
inter-sectoral into regional
inter-ethnic every kind of synapse one
can imagine in the world society has to
be engaged constructively to achieve the
goals so that the ideas and the
constructive investments and the
financing and the strategizing and the
community leadership can be accomplished
so this is a good time to have the
discussion today today we're considering
what I regard and I hope no one takes
offense or miss understands me but what
I regard is the toughest development
challenge on the planet and that is the
problem of extreme arid regions many of
you know about the millennium villages
project which has been organized to
introduced integrated rural development
strategies across the range of Africa's
agro ekos owns and what we're seeing
systematically is the dryer the
environment the tougher the challenge
and one of the highly arid zones in the
project which is in the northeast of
Kenya near the Somalia border is
absolutely the hardest site it's got
wonderful people great dedication but it
is often like like the book of Job it
feels so drought flood drought epidemic
more droughts more flood and it's been
45 years the place of tremendous
tremendous challenge and difficulty more
than in the well-watered sites of the
project where the rains come every year
and one can depend on at least adequate
rainfall for growing crops indeed in the
regions that are on the panel today most
of or much much of the respective
countries are so dry that they are not
even producing crops or very short
season small amounts of millet and
sorghum and a great deal of the
agriculture is in fact pastoralism and
transhuman pastoralism or semi-nomadic
pastoralism where the herdsmen follow
the short rains to follow the grasses
for their livestock and this is an
ecosystem under tremendous tremendous
stress if one looks at a map as we need
to do frequently the overlay of conflict
and drylands is unmistakable and a lot
of the region that we're talking about
here is conflict-ridden certainly
Somalia northern Uganda
and many other parts of this region in
the Horn of Africa side and then right
across the Red Sea to Yemen where there
is growing conflict right now that one
could foresee and I would say when we
visited it was utterly foreseeable a few
years ago as a result of growing
environmental degradation hunger water
stress dropping water tables so this is
the backdrop of today's discussions I
think it's just about the hardest
challenge we face in development and it
is therefore an incredible privilege to
have such a wonderful group of people to
talk about the challenges in the
countries in the region to set the stage
i'm going to ask our two colleagues from
the earth institute to get us started I
we have dr. Billy beggar Shah who heads
the earth Institute's Millennium
Development Goals Center in Nairobi for
east and south africa and in that
capacity dr. becca Shaw has launched a
drylands initiative aiming to cover
seven countries in the region though
only six have answered the phone so far
we're still waiting for the call from to
Eritrea to be returned we hope that will
happen but so far it's Kenya Uganda
Somalia Ethiopia djibouti Sudan and
we're hoping that Eritrea will join this
project after that I'll ask the director
of the Earth Institute water center
manilal who is our lead hydrologist at
the Earth Institute and a professor in
school of engineering who is working on
a project that's worldwide in scope
spanning brazilian semi drylands to
india his home country where he's
two major sites at work to the Sahel of
Africa specifically in Mali around sagoo
and in the coming year opening a project
site in China to describe from a global
hydrological perspective the nature of
the challenge and what dr. Lyle is
seeing on the ground in these widely
varying sites then we'll turn to our
esteemed guests and I will introduce
each one of them at the time and I'll
ask them to share with us of course some
view of the challenge that their
countries are facing help us to
understand and help us to understand how
that global partnership can can help the
process so without further ado it's my
great pleasure to welcome dr. Begich ah
the lie is many of you know him he was
for many many years Minister of
Agriculture of Ethiopia he's esteemed
throughout Africa for his leadership in
practical steps to boost agricultural
productivity and work in the drylands
and so let me turn it over to you black
Thank you Thank You professor sucks
this is a challenging assignment like
the dryland itself Thank You professor
sucks I just want to introduce to you
the new initiative for the dryland
agriculture system that's just been
launched july twenty second 2010 in
nairobi as you all know the dryland
system constitutes almost sixty percent
of africa and when it comes to the Horn
of Africa in fact out of the seven
countries that Professor Sachs mentioned
three of them are completely known for
the dryland for the dryland system
djibouti somaliland Djibouti Somalia and
the main part of Eritrea totally
characterizes under these ecosystems
whereas southern Sudan Ethiopia Uganda
and Kenya although the magnitude is
quite different particularly in Kenya
the dryland is estimated to be like
eighty percent of the total land mass
but in most of these countries they have
more than one ecosystem including
Highlands rainfall above eight hundred
and eight hundred millimeter other
rainfall and sedentary kind of farming
systems while the dryland system
constitutes different cervical systems I
just this program is mainly focusing on
the transhuman or the past forest system
the password is subsystem in the Horn of
Africa Kony is a big subsystem actually
the estimated number of population
living under this system is about 20
million so imagine meeting MDG goals
without involving 20 million of people
and imagine when we claim that
mdgs is about everybody particularly
about pores and particularly about the
Forgotten segment of the population if
we don't include and embrace this large
size of population no matter challenging
the problem is I think we will not be
meeting the promise that we set for the
world so we start considering how best
we can tackle this problem and the
experience of dirt to the turtle site in
northern Kenya shows us that this is a
very challenging but at the same time a
doable kind of thing and we have
concluded that if this is something that
can be done how ways we can expedite and
enhance you know achievements in this
regard particularly when we are scaling
up this development practice in many
countries and countries who have never
been involved in this kind of integrated
development work so we had to ponder on
these issues for about six months
creating different forums inviting
different people expertise including
high-level policy makers who actually
believed to be engaged and included
right from the inception phase so the
objective of this program is is mainly
to in bringing the deep assess
communities into the mainstream of
economic development so that they can
make meaningful contribution to the
development and the GDP making of their
countries and maybe the second most
important objective is also overcoming
the historical and current misconception
about the dryland system and people
living in the dryland and which actually
result would bring hope to millions of
people
have suffered from this neglect for
years the program is essentially an
integrated development approach but an
integrated development approach in the
area where nothing of the basic
components are available these areas are
not only transhumans not only suffers
from erratic rainfall situation drought
and flood as Professor Sachs mention but
also these areas are known to have no
essential services and basic
infrastructures at all so if you start
if you have to start the program here we
have to start from zero and in fact we
have the most important challenges to
bring in all these essential components
in such a way that they can create some
kind of critical mass or threshold for
kicking of development so from this
point of view we strongly believe that
it is the only way to tackle this
problem is to develop an integrated
development approach not all that takes
care of everything of course essential
things including infrastructure health
education and others and not only
comprehensive but also something that
should be done simultaneously if we
don't tackle these things simultaneously
we will not be able to kick off or to
create the kind of threshold that we are
expecting this program has to creighton
so with this basic assumptions actually
we started working on the program itself
and this is a 3gs program basically the
first one is at the grassroots level
where people are living and where people
have actually striving to survive we
have to come with this basic kind of
infrastructures and development
activities but we pointed out as an
entry point water is a critical element
there
so we are trying to develop all other
things around water and on top of water
the other very critical entry point is
to actually increase the take-off level
of their livestock resources because
livestock resources are are there as you
know but most of the time the natural
harvest or the natural days of livestock
resource is reached to the level of
fifty to sixty percent even in a good
year a good year in a sense a year
without drought or result flood so we
are trying to bring in this basic
infrastructure closer to the people we
are not expecting these people to go to
the market and meet and comply you know
is what the market is looking for at
this stage we are trying to bring the
market toward the same by bringing up
some of the basic things that I
mentioned in a very energetic way this
so we will be having some kind of unit
for intervention and this unit is
defined as in this case as basic grazing
in it the basic grazing we need is a
unit where each clan is focused I mean
is thinking or as something that it
possesses for running the particularly
the livestock enterprises so we want to
focus on those and to bring in all these
development facilities together the
other the second tiers of this program
is at a national level we strongly
believe that many of in many countries
actually the existing national policies
are not reflecting the real life and
real development challenge of these
areas governments like any other
entities have been investing their
resources on the areas where they feel
like they would get
you know QQ in kind of reward and
dividends so we would like to see how
based national governments will
accommodate this challenging areas into
their national strategy documents
policies and also action plans including
budgets and and other essential inputs
for development so we will be having a
very very basic and same time but very
important interventions particularly a
policy level intervention at all level
in national national levels but we also
try to actually help the national
capacity building programs in such a way
that they can have you know competent
human resources and additional
capacities to follow up and also to
pursue the kind of development
activities that we are trying to
demonstrate their the third level in the
very interesting level where we believe
that at least the minimum forty percent
of the Holy 14 resource should go is the
regional level at regional level will be
because we believe that these areas
regardless of the geopolitical
demarcations and borders these are areas
under the same ecosystem problems are
more or less homogeneous and solutions
particularly technical solutions can be
easily actually easily transferred from
one corner to the other provider that
that kind of facilities and willingness
is there so we are trying actually to
build a regional capacity that will
focus on basic regional issues like
early warning system immunization for
livestock and human
the human being basic epidemiology
systems and also measure infrastructure
and catchment approach and also
development of the hydrological systems
so in this case the regional approach is
going to be harmonized through national
level policy work so that every single
person and living in this ecosystem can
have a feeling of living and actually
trading whatever resources that has
within the exhibit the current region
set up this is something that is going
to be coordinated in fact at regional
level but it's going to be implemented
both at national and grassroots level so
in order to implement this thing in
totally the we will be having like two
levels of alliances the first alliance
is a political level kind of aliens
where the number of number of ministers
from each of these countries and
regional organizations like camisa
African Union and others will be engaged
with and mainly focusing on harmonizing
policy environments so that at the end
of the day we will be able to create a
single economic space where people can
do as I said in carry out not only their
daily life but also their major
businesses in the region the second
Alliance is allowance of technical
capacities this includes individuals as
well as institutions this also involves
all other institutions that are engaged
in dryland system and we will be
expecting a lot of networking and
informations and also harmonizing
experiences through this approach
so this program is going to be
implemented at least in the six of the
seven countries and we are expecting to
have at least 10 different grazing units
or like Millennium village kind of areas
as a basic need for intervention and
we'll be carrying out a lot of capacity
development in policy work at national
and regional level and more importantly
we are expecting the international
community's and also people of with you
know experiences and expertise to
contribute through these channels and
the endeavors that we are striving to
actually make differences in the dryland
part of this battlefield thank
thanks a lot I'm sure that you get an
idea of how complex this challenges and
maybe a glimpse of how bereft some of
the major challenges have been of the
active participation and investment for
a long time these regional structures
don't exist the National structures
don't exist the local areas have largely
been abandoned and people are hurting
and it's very complex and balai has
created a new wave of hope and
enthusiasm among the countries and when
he called for this meeting in July I
think was 18 ministers that showed up at
the mdg headquarters and partnership of
comme SI which is the community of east
in southern african countries and they
will be the real partners and the
implement implementing regional body for
for the project let me turn it next to
Professor man allow and we'll get a view
from some different parts of the world
and also not pastoralism as he'll
describe but the water stressed
agriculture thanks very much Jeff I
taught maybe I should start by giving
what some people consider a definition
of the dry lands and then go from there
to connecting that to a water challenge
and then we talked about some of the
locations of interests so some people
define dry lands as regions where the
average annual rainfall is less than six
hundred fifty millimeters you'll be
surprised to find what places fall in
those categories so I'm going to talk
about some of them and all the ones that
Jeff mentioned that we are working on
fall in that category but as Jeff also
mentioned and belay also mentioned the
striking thing about many of the dry
lands is not the amount of rainfall you
get on the average but the fluctuation
the fluctuation comes for example where
the average where the rainfall for the
year may drop as low as 50 millimeters
or rise to 2,000 in the same location
where the average is 650 so that's
pretty spectacular what's more
spectacular about it is the climate
context of these changes are these years
can come in not randomly here and there
but they can come in rows so you can get
five years in a row where you are wiped
out by floods 10 years in a row the
biblical seven and seven could be a
better example perhaps but that's what
happens in these places and that's that
makes for a significant challenge that's
what I'm going to call interannual
variability or across here's what's also
remarkable in these places is that
typically you may only get 10 to 20
rainfall events in a given year and it
doesn't matter whether it was a dry year
or a wet here so now imagine picking up
two meters of rainfall in a place which
is very arid so it doesn't have much
landscaping or ecology and suddenly you
get these dumps in 10 to 20 events this
doesn't make for the best living
conditions it leads to situations where
agriculture is difficult which means
food is hard to come by it makes for a
situation in which disease whether it is
vector-borne disease or waterborne
disease is rampant and that's the
challenge of water that comes in these
places so how do we deal with these
challenges you know this is just the
first part of the story so let's imagine
first that we are in the drive phase of
this climatic cycle so you could get
water through groundwater which means
you need to have some form of energy to
extract that okay if you are in the wet
face maybe it's not such a big issue but
then the quality of the water becomes an
issue so this is the challenge what is
this challenge translate into some work
we did a few years at a global scale
showed us the following if you looked at
every single country in the world and
characterized it by average annual
rainfall by the across here variability
in rainfall
and by the within year variability in
rainfall we learned that the poorest
countries in the world were the ones
that had high variability in rainfall
across years high variability in rain
fall within the years and it didn't
really matter so much what the average
annual rainfall was you know so that's
interesting the exception to that story
is of course the countries that have a
lot of oil by the same token if you go
to the countries that have the highest
GDP among all in all nations they have
low variability in rainfall and modest
amounts of average annual rainfall not
super high okay so even at the macro
level and this is jeff story in many
ways that climate has a big role it
plays in terms of the final outcomes
that you can measure in terms of income
and we see that so that's the challenge
now how can we address this challenge
and that's what we are doing in the
countries brazil northeast in here tube
locations punjab and gujarat punjab is
the breadbasket of india so it's sort of
odd to think that that's a dry land but
it is and so if a dry land can become
the breadbasket of a nation as populous
as India you think there is hope that
hope is tempered by the fact that Punjab
is extracting wrong water at a high rate
so they're living on borrowed time in a
way so my story that if you have access
to energy you can and you can extract
groundwater is a good one but everything
must be done in moderation and that's
hard to do once you have access to
technology so that's the challenge to
some extent in India groundwater levels
drop in Punjab by a meter per year in
Gujarat by three to five meters per year
and the graphic there is this is the
land of Gandhi Gujarat is the place of
Gandhi where he led a demonstration
against the British mind your own salt
he said and we are in danger of turning
Gujarat into a salty wasteland because
the water levels have dropped now to a
hundred to two hundred meters below
sea level and at a hundred kilometers
from the ocean so that's the challenge
that we faced there we work in China and
we are trying to choose the Yangtze
River Basin the mighty Yangtze and
people think this cannot be the dry land
of course this is the place that is
known for floods and in fact the first
purpose of building the Three Gorges Dam
is to control floods but if you go into
the upper catchment of the Yangtze which
is southwest China its arid and it's a
dry land so dry lands come in many forms
you know is what we learn and hear our
story is we are trying to learn through
different examples what can be done
examples that are advanced in a state of
degradation as I mentioned for India
examples such as Northeast Brazil where
we are trying to figure out still how to
manage some of this variability what
people do to manage this whether you're
in the United States and in the West or
in these countries is to initially build
large surface water storages so if you
look at the Colorado River Project it's
capable of holding between five to ten
years of average annual flow if you look
at the delaware river that supplies new
york it holds a few months of water
average and in terms of the average
supply so that's the difference so if
you can build a storage that large and
if you ask about the African drylands
the challenge we see is that they have
neither large storages built to supply
the population nor do they have have
they had intensive efforts to build
significant rain water harvesting or
aquifer recharging capability which are
the solutions we have been looking at
elsewhere in the world so that's on the
supply side with the Punjab example I
wanted to highlight that if your
ambition is to become the breadbasket of
a country in the drylands that's not
such a good idea one has to choose the
crops you grow and how you grow them
judiciously and that's the major lesson
that we learn from that particular
endpoint so I want to I can talk on this
for hours but I don't have hours so what
I'm going to do is I'm going to close
off by highlighting the key points
climate variability is a big issue you
can manage that with surface or
subsurface storage the harsher
conditions require adaptability in terms
what you grow there and what you do
there the fact that climate is
persistent in these places in the dry or
wet phase and has a very high amplitude
of fluctuation suggests in many cases
that climatic predictability could be
very high what that says is that you
could start out before the season in
which you're going to grow a crop and
have a pretty good idea of what might
happen that gives you a strategy for
adaptability whether you're talking
about climate change in the future or
where you are talking about the dramatic
variation we see in these places this is
counterintuitive because many people
think that a place that has very high
fluctuations must not have
predictability and it is random another
way of thinking about that is if you
don't have much variability there's not
much to predict so that's one of the
bright spots that one can think about in
terms of the drylands with that I'll say
that I am very hopeful that in terms of
the initiative that is being launched we
can come up with solutions that are at
the larger scales and at the village
scales that harmoniously can lead to a
much better outcome than what we have
seen in these places
you can see that when you're dealing
with water you want mono on your side
and we're very grateful for all the wins
it now let's turn to our honored guests
and we have three countries represented
here uganda Djibouti and Somalia and let
me start over on my far left and your
right to introduce a shiba ruka Kerry
who was the head of the drylands program
in karamoja northern Uganda and the
first lady of Uganda madam OU 70 is also
the minister of this region and is also
on the Governing Board of the drylands
initiative that that bill I started to
discuss so it's really wonderful to have
you here and if you could tell us about
Tara moja and the challenges and what
kinds of solutions you're envisioning
that would be tremendous and you're very
welcome to come up to come up to the
podium
Thank You Cara Maria is a sub-region
located in the north eastern part of
Uganda bordering Kenya the dry lands of
Kenya and also Sudan it is a it has a
population of just over 1 million people
the population of Uganda is actually
about 30 million now the people of
karamoja are pastoralists and they are
nomads their their culture is nomadic
they move around with their cattle
looking for water and for pasture some
of them are grow pastoralists and they
try to keep in one place and actually
grow food when they have rain the
sub-region is potentially rich it has
fertile soils it is actually a big a big
region in terms of size because it is
ten percent of Uganda even though it has
a population of only 1 million people
there have been about three factors
which has kept Karamoja behind the rest
of the country in terms of development
one was discussed of the resource that
is very important which is water which
has kept them moving from one place to
another and therefore when you are not
settled you don't you don't really
develop these people live they are
controlled by the welfare of their
cattle they must make sure they are
cattle have
water and they have pasture that is
their priority therefore it is hard for
them to settle down and help schools and
have hospitals and have all these are
the things which the rest of the country
has the second one is conflict they
there has been a long-term conflict for
decades these people have been
conflicting raiding cattle there are
several ethnic groups in the area and
they are all cut rocky paths and they
raid cattle from one another and this
creates conflict and conflict is one of
the factors therefore which has kept the
region behind lagging behind in terms of
development the third one we must admit
is that the government in the past have
tended to marginalize the region and to
keep it on the periphery in terms of
planning because the rest of the country
is rich in agriculture rich in rainfall
they are settled a live a sedentary
lifestyle so I guess karamoja has
suffered by being a minority these three
have combined to ensure that Cara moja
sub-region has the worst indices in
terms of human development Parvati
infant mortality maternal mortality
education everything they come with the
highest worst possible indicators now to
give you an example of how severe the
situation can be it had not until this
year it had not rained in karamoja foda
for four years
so the people lived on food aid totally
completely lived on food aid they they
raided one another's cattle they were
under and displaced populations and it
was not possible really even with the
best of goodwills to bring development
to her people as unsettled as this the
government however has set in place a
program which is called the Karamoja
integrated disarmament and the
development program ki DDT which
involves pacification and as well as
development it is the people of Cara
Maria themselves are beginning to
realize that they cannot sustain the
lifestyle of nomadism because borders
have been drawn between districts the
neighbors don't want any disturbances
from them so they they are convinced
that it is important for them to settle
down so the government came up with this
program after discussion with the
leaders of the Kurama Jerome the people
are called the Kurama drawn in this
program we realize that the most
important the key factor is water if
people are going to settle down they
have to have water they so that they
don't go chasing after water but they
settle around where the water is so the
intervention the largest the most
important intervention the government is
trying to introduce is water for both
for cultural
and for production terms of Agriculture
and also for human consumption and so
the government is looking at different
alternatives it is important to to know
that karamoja actually doesn't have to
be so dry because it has over 30 rivers
and streams some of them seasonal
streams which when it does rain as the
gentleman who was just spoken said all
the the rivers and the streams fill up
and they actually overflow but the water
quickly runs off to the next place and
the rivers dry again and the country
side is dry again so it is possible to
actually truck this water we are looking
at examples of the punjabi area which
the gentleman the speaker before has
just talked about to dumb this water in
the rainy season when it comes to do
what they call check dams and we are
looking at tapping the underground water
and and damning water from the mountains
it's a region with a lot of mountains
all those alternatives so that around
then those dams and water sources human
settlements can be developed with
hospitals with schools and all the other
interventions which which we look at
when we talk about human development
therefore we were excited
when we were approached by drylands
initiative and we are happy we we are
very happy to to have them because the
integrated approach they are talking
about is really what we are talking
about and we think that they are going
to compliment us and contribute to that
development that we already have in
place for Cara Maria I'm happy to inform
you also that the place is now quickly
being pacified the conflict the
skirmishes are here and there they are
not really very serious and very soon we
hope that we are going to have a
peaceful karamoja and when Cara moja is
peaceful and it has water it is likely
in the near future to be a food basket
for this region lastly I want to say
that the government is also working very
hard to disc engage the other countries
in the region who have the same problem
especially Kenya and Sudan so that we
can pacify the whole region because when
these cows are stolen from one tribe
they are sometimes taken across the
border and the government has no way of
following because they cannot cross the
border because we don't have
understanding and agreements with our
neighbors we are seriously in
discussions now and negotiations and we
should soon have protocols which will
make sure that we are talking with our
neighbors and we should be able to
pacify this region the most important
thing of course is the mindset of the
Kurama drunk themselves and I must say
they are coming around very quickly
because they can see that at last
the government has serious intentions
and goodwill towards them and they are
willing to cooperate so I have very high
hopes for the sub-regional Cara Maria
thank you very much so you have been
looking at me while I was sitting there
I was scribbling something what to say
and I think I have enough thank you for
this new initiative the dryland
initiative which the Earth Institute has
initiated through the efforts of many in
Columbia University and the
international community but I would like
to comment the professor sack for his
selfless dedication to reduce the plight
of many in the developing countries
particularly in Africa to reduce poverty
he has dedicated himself to the
achievement of the millinery millennium
development goals I have known him for
quite some time since he has been
working with kofi annan and how he has
been so devoted and all the literature
that that unit in the united nations
development programme has put out so
we're really thankful for your effort
this tireless efforts asst i think i'm
going to talk about Djibouti and the way
i will explain to you about djibouti
city most of you don't you know the
Republic of Djibouti I would like to say
that I think you know if you appear I
think you know Somalia I think you know
eritrea if you know all these three
countries then djibouti is a neighbor
that's the way I like to describe for
most of you who don't know where we are
located or who have not ever heard of
Djibouti so if you appear Somali Eritrea
are our neighbors and our for the
neighbor happens to be the Red Sea by
far the most peaceful
so I'd like to say something about
djibouti wish I just described all them
now so that you know something about
djibouti djibouti is a very small
country about 20,000 square kilometers
less than 1 million population highly
challenge it by climatic difficulties it
is hot irate rocky dry and I think it
fits very well with the initiative of
the dryland we have many challenges
first of all were woefully deficient
with water among the 25 countries in the
world that are deficient in water
djibouti is at the top in fact we are
told in 20 years the country will run
out of freshwater completely out of
fresh water in 20 years so we are very
very highly deficient in fresh water and
of course you can agree with me in
agriculture less than fifteen percent of
our country is arable or cultivable so
I'm gonna do all the piece all the
pessimistic scenarios and information
and then finally I'll try to get some
optimistic scenarios for the country
around just like to live with pessimism
so we'll have something for you rain is
very scarce as you would expect
there is no period we call the rainy
season we welcome it when it comes it
does come but rarely our biggest
handicap is electricity for industrial
development or for generating jobs
because since the electricity is very
very expensive most private sector
investment is are rare in the country
mainly because of this particular issue
and that is the insufficiency of
electricity and the cost of electricity
in order to overcome this major handicap
we are doing something very great and
now we are doing an interconnection with
if you appear is a huge project financed
by the African Development Bank and the
two countries are collaborating and the
work is underway so that might relieve
both the shortage and the costliness of
electricity so we have one hope on that
score for us achieving the Millennium
Development Goals is very very crucial
and I want to Professor Sachs to know
that djibouti is a country that should
be made a test case not only in terms of
it is dryness but in terms of it the
challenges it is facing in terms of
water most particular
then you talk about foods if that is the
case how do you survive would you get
your foods from certainly we get a lot
of foods most of the foods from outside
we import practical everything hardly
twenty percent or fifty percent
agriculture we have but rest everything
is important I think for the sake of
brevity let me say something about the
country in terms of what it does for its
own population despite all these
handicaps all these challenges all this
is scary stories and i'd like to share
with you that this is small and poor
country highly challenged country
happens to be the least known warfare
state perhaps in the world and this is
what it does djibouti provides primary
secondary and university education free
all the three levels of education free
to have a new university now is not full
fledged some students go there in the
last few years but traditionally we have
been giving scholarships to our student
is to go abroad and they study we are
still doing it since the new university
cannot absorb all the students or all
the fields of study were still sending
them
broad I know how much university
education costs us here so this is a
very interesting element for you to
wander over I know I have children here
and have educated them in this country
and I know how much education cause this
but this is small poor and highly
challenging country provides free
education for the entire population
second it provides free health care not
only for our own population but for all
the other people from the region who
flow into the country for one reason or
another migrant is economic migrants
refugees others others others we give
them free health care as well so that is
why and I'm not overstating by saying
that and the professor's will agree with
me I'm sure that this is small country
is by far the least in on warfare
country in the world word we are a
service economy since we don't grow and
we don't have any known resources in
terms of minerals at the moment
potential maybe or oil petroleum nothing
you are a service economy we rely on
service is based on see we have a big
Morita import huge one and we built a
new one a major container port now and
the full terminal huge so that is the
mainstay of the economy the backbone of
the economy and from there we have a lot
of services transshipment commerce
banking and transport
and a lot of investment is around that
and we have a free zone also and have a
free exchange also together with the
generosity and support of the
international community I think you are
surviving I think you have peace I think
you have relative democracy I think you
are on the map and we are doing well
thank
thank you very much and thank you for
the commitment which I know firsthand
and and from you ambassador to the
Millennium Development Goals and the
very impressive achievements of the
country let me introduce the final
panelist who is in a very special
position he is the special envoy to the
United States of the government of
Somalia and this is a new position and a
new hope for the country and we look
forward mr. special envoy to what you're
telling us about the situation in a
country that has been fraught with the
with violence and and political disarray
and is now we hope pulling being able to
pull together for progress please good
evening ladies and gentlemen when it
comes to famine somebody happens to be
the poster child when it comes to failed
estate Somalia happens to be the poster
child and I'm not standing before you to
brag about those two status but to tell
you that most of it is man-made and
failures are not permanent state unless
the people decide to be in that so taken
from there I want to also tell you that
and you may or may not agree with this
that everything ecological everything
humanitarian is also political and
Somali new this long time ago before the
rest of the world knew when the rain is
short in one region tribes migrate from
one area to the other it creates
problems
if any particular group wants to build a
hospital today in Somalia it's a
humanitarian act until they decide which
region they want to build in and all of
a sudden it's political so you cannot
really discuss one area of this
initiative without really addressing the
political environment in which its
supposed to function where partnerships
are supposed to succeed and everything
else so with that I want to just
describe Somali a little bit and then
sit down and entertain any questions and
comments from the audience I won't make
it long in order to understand that
country its current estate while Africa
is celebrating 50 years of independence
here is a nation that turn into itself
introspectively and trying to find out
what have gone wrong and how to correct
these things so when I think about it
and I want you to also think about it in
that metaphoric sense a patient who
suffers from multiple chronic illnesses
and the patient is comatose and the
family is divided into two primarily one
half that wants to talk about which
illness should be addressed first see
the visible injuries the self-inflicted
ones or the hemorrhage or the heart that
stopped functioning or the brain that's
threatened and so forth and so on and
they fight over there and then on the
other side you have those who are
corrupted those who can make the deals
those who are going for the ring and all
the jewelry and dig in the pockets and
doing all kinds of things and then you
have an international
that looks at that patient and says why
is the patient not paying his bills why
is the patient not raising his family
why is the patient not participating in
marathons and really exercising and
developed from plans and so forth and so
on so that's the dilemma so now under
that environment we have to make
partnerships with good+ projects as
supposed to be successful but these are
the challenges so we can approach it two
ways one way one option would be devoid
of the political discussion just focus
on that initiative as is not just this
particular initiative but all
initiatives that are humanitarian that
are all good or address also the
political environment without security
not a whole lot will happen so I hope
that we turn to the more positive one
that we address this issue in a holistic
sense thank you
thank you very much for that very vivid
description and challenge I hope
everybody has I'm sure everybody
appreciates by now how complex this
region is and how complex the challenges
are I count in terms of the kind of
expertise and I'm now talking to the
students especially the kinds of
expertise that are needed and that need
to be mobilized within the region and
internationally to understand the
challenges and help hope to address them
and that includes climate ology
hydrology engineering landscape ecology
public health economics politics
veterinary medicine business agronomy
and culture in its many aspects and that
is I think nothing less than the
enormity of the challenge that's faced
but I think we've seen in all of the
speakers a very impressive vision and
commitment in in the region and I want
to say that the Earth Institute is very
eager to be your partner in this and we
view this effort as something that will
be sustained over many years and we hope
that we can grasp the the not only the
complexity but the situation from the
point of view of the people affected so
that they can find and lead their way
out of these challenges with the help
that you as government will be offering
and that we we hope as scientific
partners can can offer as well so this
is where we stand this has been a very
rich discussion it's formerly the end of
time for the session and spent a long
long discussion and you've been very
patient if there are a couple of
questions let's take a couple of urgent
questions if people would go to the
microphone and otherwise well let's let
me give you time for that if there are
please introduce yourself and direct
your question to any of the panel
members okay thank you my name is Rhonda
shafi I'm a third year student in
Columbia College I want to thank you on
behalf of the students here at cumbia
for coming and speaking us and give us
some very interesting stories and
backgrounds on this issue my question
pertains to the Nile Basin initiative
currently ongoing in Africa how does the
current dispute between the East African
bloc and the Egyptian and sudanese
parties affect the drylands initiative
and my second question it's my belief
and please correct me if I'm wrong that
the Egyptian party is not member of the
initiative and that the southern
Sudanese government is but not that of
President Bush here in the north so how
does the inclusion or the lack of
inclusion of these two parties affect
the ongoing discussion maybe I'll ask
able I to give a first answer to that
when we first right into the mic closer
this initiative is mainly in those
countries that are fallen under the East
Africa actually these countries are
Colonel known for their not only for the
dryland system but also they are known
to be having a pastoralist system that
cross cut across this 67 countries Egypt
is far from here actually and Egypt is
not included in the program but when we
identify these areas we intentionally
focused on those areas where the Dryad
system is predominantly
active in each of these countries like
northern Kenya southern northern Uganda
eastern part of Ethiopia and Djibouti
Somalia and thousand part of Sudan
because if you see these countries they
are neighbors they are sharing borders
and the same time most of the people who
are living in these areas are sharing
common value of transhuman kind of
farming system so that's how the
inclusiveness and the exclusiveness of
countries be set and determined when it
comes to the Nile initiative this is
something that has been going on for a
while there are some developments these
days actually something that has been
expected to be signed off on the treaty
after five six years of hard work it
hasn't taken place yet we strong I mean
we have a feeling like the discussion is
ongoing and things may be changed and
however still I mean having this kind of
initiatives maybe actually complement to
the big effort where the national
initiative is devoting too so i think we
are part and parcel of the nile
catchment but at the same time you know
there are areas where none of these
rivers are making a big difference in
the life and the livelihood of these
people so we have to take up this kind
of initiatives and pursue as much as
possible while the nile discussion is
going on
I think that with the hour late and I
don't see any other questioners right
now let me take the opportunity there
for to thank this wonderful panel
especially thank our guests at the
University for coming and spending the
time and giving us such thoughtful
comments and observations about their
countries I want to say to the students
and to everybody else that as we
launched this initiative we are always
keen on student engagement and partners
and involvement this is going to be many
years of fascinating challenge with the
wonderful counterparts in these
countries we have a new major for the
first time this year we're very excited
a major in sustainable development and
within that context this program
obviously exemplifies what sustainable
development means a holistic human
natural environment interaction in all
its complexity and I think you can see
why such a major is needed and we hope
that students here will get very much
involved and see the fascination and the
need for this kind of knowledge to all
of you please join me in thanking our
panel
you